not a day goes by in ai research in
which we don't get a new image
generation model these days so take a
look at the top row right here and
listen to the prompt that generated them
oil on canvas painting of a blue night
sky with roiling energy a fuzzy and
bright yellow crescent moon shining at
the top below the exploding yellow stars
and radiating swirls of blue a distant
village sits quietly on the right
connecting earth and sky is a flame-like
cypress tree with curling and swaying
swaying branches on the left
a church spire rises as a beacon over
rolling blue hills
that is a 67 word description of starry
night by vincent van gogh and it is also
the prompt that generated the top row of
images and the paper does this to show
that image generation models
specifically this one they have become
super duper capable of incorporating not
only a wild concept as you can see here
co-locating the eiffel tower with the
sydney skyline and fireworks and and
whatnot but also
you know my new details about things in
the image and where things are and how
things look so we've gone from
essentially
conditional gans where we could create
one of 10 classes to something where we
can input like a little essay about what
we want to see and get it get it out so
this is by a group of researchers of
researchers out of google research and
uh they are a parallel work to the
imogen model that you might have seen so
this model or the paper is called
scaling auto aggressive models for
content rich text to image generation
but the uh the model is called let me
grab if i can
let me grab pen the model is called
p
a
r t i
and i have no clue how to pronounce this
this could be
party
uh maybe the the pronunciation is on the
art or on the part
because it's pathways like it's
huh
or part tie
or i have no idea let's call it party
and party is a model that generates
images from text as we have so many
models however it doesn't do this in the
same style as like imogen which is a
diffusion model it is an autoregressive
model so here you can see a bunch of
other outputs like this this is insane
look at the left side right here
a photo of a frog reading the newspaper
named toe day
that the newspaper is named toe day like
how crazy is that um
that in itself is pretty funny
but we know that these image to sorry
these text to image models are pretty
bad at spelling stuff in images well not
this model as you can see right here it
gets it completely right it doesn't
always get it right but it gets it right
often enough or this one portrait of a
statue of the egyptian god anubis
wearing aviator goggles like
uh
another connoisseur of uh fine eyewear i
see white t-shirt and the leather jacket
the city of los angeles is in the
background hi-res dslr photograph that's
literally that's the academic version of
the unreal engine trick right here and
you can see the images spot on so this
requires a lot of knowledge not only of
you know
you know how what a dslr photograph is
but also how the skyline of los angeles
looks how the egyptian god anubis looks
right and the composition of things
together like these this god was never
in a leather jacket depicted i guess
maybe on the on the internet you'll find
anything
but you can see a bunch of more examples
right here i specifically love the thing
on the left side here you can see that
they generated images so the prompt is
three-quarters front view of a xyz
coming around a curve in a mountain road
looking over a green valley on a cloudy
day so x here is any of the colors blue
red and yellow why is any of the numbers
uh
1977 1997 and 2017 and z is any of these
car types and now
look that the model can essentially
track
the
uh
the historical evolution of these cars
so not only does it know what a porsche
is it also knows how a porsche in 77
looked like or maybe it's not exactly
the correct year but this is pretty
crazy you can see a bunch more examples
right here they do a lot of examples
with animals i specifically like the
raccoon here in
the style of cubism
so this is going to be very very
powerful technology we can immediately
see that
you know the quality of these models
gets fast gets quickly sorry gets well
gets better so quickly that in the
foreseeable future we're going to have
super powerful tools to just create and
edit images from text look at the left
side here a giant cobra snake made from
salad
like
you know
i'm sure like they even say these are
cherry picked but still this is insane
now i would love to tell you that behind
all of this
cool development is a really cool idea
like is a smart architecture and
something like this but i'm afraid it is
not it is simply scale and
not simply scale i mean you have to have
the sort of correct uh base architecture
there is nothing like particularly
there's no cool invention in
architecture or a neat trick involved or
anything like this it's really just plug
basic things together make them really
big train them for long on a lot of data
and you'll get quality so this is the
model overview right here the overview
of this party or part-time model
this is as i already said in contrast to
imogen it is an auto-regressive model so
not a diffusion model what happens is
that on this side here you have this
vqgan image encoder and decoder well
they call they don't call them encoder
and decoder they call them tokenizer and
d tokenizer
so if you are not aware
autoregressive models they work on
tokens now tokens in usually
in natural language processing are words
or
part of words so these would be tokens
token one token two and so on until
token n and then you what you would try
to do is you would try always to predict
the next token that's what makes it
autoregressive you feed in parts of a
token sequence like parts of a sentence
you try to predict the next one that's
exactly what you see right here in the
architecture so you pass in the start of
sentence token you try to predict the
first token and you pass in the first
token and then from these two you try to
predict the second token and then you
put that here from these three you try
to predict the third token and so on
that's the auto regressivity in text
that works well however in images uh
it's not quite obvious how to do that
that's why you first need to
get from the image space to the token
space so we need a way uh for any given
image that we get out a sequence of
tokens and
it can't be the pixels themselves like
we
um we would like to have tokens that are
kind of latent and have sort of a bit of
meaning not just individual pixels
because that first of all is too many
pixels and second of all um there's not
too much
let's say
information in
the single pixel
so what we do is we have these image
tokenizer and determinizer this is a a
vq gan that is powered by a vision
transformer
so essentially this is a model that
takes this image it ships it through a
bunch of layers and at the end
so let's say the image at the beginning
has a bunch of rows a bunch of columns
with its pixels
this goes through a series of maybe down
scalings and so on i know actually it's
because it's a vision transformer it
probably even tokenizes like it um
patches the image at the very beginning
so these would be image patches then
these are transformed by a transformer
to a latent space maybe they are
compressed
and
then you get tokens so you at the end
you can take these these uh things right
here or the things that correspond to
them in the latent representation you
can take those as image tokens and you
can unroll essentially this image and
then feed it into this model
hey just a short interjection here from
yannick from the future the idea i
forgot uh the idea behind the whole
setup here is behind the whole
vq gan is obviously that these things
here
are tokens which means that they come
from a set vocabulary so the way you
train a vq gan isn't just to give you
this latent representation of like token
like things but then you also quantize
them so there is also a vocabulary
somewhere where uh you have a set
defined set of tokens i believe in their
case they have like eight eight thousand
tokens or so
and your image
that your image tokens must be
of these 8 000 so the image has a bunch
of tokens but they all must be one of
the things in the vocabulary here now
the vocabulary is also learned
there are some techniques by which to
learn the vocabulary but this
quantization is actually what then
enables you to treat essentially to
treat it as a sequence of language
tokens which also come from a vocabulary
all right back to yannick in the past
the image tokenizer is trained as an as
a as it says here as a vq gan which
means that you encode and then you
decode again and you try to get out the
same image and at the end this
representation here in the middle is
really valuable because it's a tokenized
representation of an image
so
you put that into the transformer
right here
and this is as we said an autoregressive
model so it gets as an input obviously
the sequence so far it tries to predict
the next image token but also it gets as
an input the text so this is the prompt
that the user
puts in
so the prompt is
a is encoded in a transformer encoder
and is then fed in as a side input as
a target for attention so whenever in
the layer here you have queries keys and
values i'm going to guess the query can
also look at the transformer encoder the
query can also look at the keys right
here so over here you'd only have keys
and
values if you
don't know what they attend what this
all of this means
i have a video on attention is all you
need where you can learn how attention
mechanisms work so essentially
the way this is trained is the following
you attach a sentence here or a
description of an image and you attach
an image right here the image is then
patched it is fed through the
um vqgan encoder its latent
representation is obtained that latent
representation
is put here
and then you essentially train a decoder
language model that has cross attention
into the text representation
of uh of the prompt
so you simply train this thing right
here like you would train a gpt model or
any other model and this thing right
here is trained as i said as an image
reconstruction model
and this thing right here is trained i
guess jointly with this actually don't
no this could this could not be
true but i think it is true i think it
is trained jointly
so that's the model as i said is very
basic i wish i could tell you something
more interesting right here but i can't
um
it's a standard
you know bunch of transformers in
sequence essentially every single
component right here is a transformer
and because every single thing is a
transformer you can scale this thing
by a lot
by the way um
here you can see
a bunch of the i'm not going to go into
the architectural details quite uh
quite as much
but they do also train an up sampler so
they have images of resolution 256x256
ultimately
they do train an up sampler as well
where
um so here this is the up sampler super
resolution up sampler where they can go
from their pipeline which does 256 by
256 to a
what
1 10 24 by 10 24
picture essentially but this is just up
sampling right so there is i mean
technically no extra information right
here this doesn't get to look at the
prompt or anything like this it simply
gets to look at this image and then make
a four times larger image out of that
so where did we live leave off oh yeah i
also wanted to say if you now want to
get an image out of this thing so not
training but inference what you do is
you attach only the prompt right here
right you encode the prompt you put the
start of sentence token right here you
let the model generate one then you put
that here two then you put that here
three and so on you let the model
generate the image tokens here you take
those image tokens you feed you arrange
it into the latent representation of the
vqgan and you use the decoder right here
in order to generate the final image
so that's the whole flow
and then you put it through the super
resolution if you want that here you can
see the basics
the basic architectural layouts so there
is the smallest model has 350 million
parameter you can see it has 12 encoder
and 12 decoder layer it's pretty
standard transformer
scaling laws right here i mean scaling
laws pretty standard transformer
architectural
laws
um they go through a 750 million
parameter model 3 billion and the last
one here has 20
billion parameters so that's a decently
sized model it's not as large as the
large language models um and they do use
things like sparse conv attention and
things like this but it is you know it's
it's pretty large i would say you could
not run that at home very easily
so where does that get us they have a
big description right here how they
solve this architecturally how they
sharp the model how they use parallelism
which is very interesting i'm just not a
expert at it so if you're interested
i'll leave you to read this part i i
found the at least the drawings here
pretty cool so apparently this the uh
signal is routed like you know like so
like
so
and so
so like in
like a snake type of arrangement so that
always you can pipeline so that always
one thing is essentially busy as you
send data to the next thing and so on
but as i said i'm not
the expert in this
and i'd rather want to get to
the other things which are
the data sets that they use so they have
three data sets three main data sets
right here one is ms coco now ms coco
as they show right here for the image on
the right hand side
it simply says a bowl of broccoli and
apples with a utensil so it just kind of
is a high level description of what's in
the image it's like an image
simple image caption right for this
image right here
whereas the localized narratives
data set you can see that its
description is way longer it's uh more
linguistically prosaic uh but it is also
much more descriptive of the actual
image like so the top is if you want to
tell someone what's in an image and the
bottom is more like if you want to like
really paint the picture like no pun
intended or if you want to describe the
picture to someone so that they could
maybe recreate it in some way
and it turns out that we are now at the
point with these image generation models
where they are so good that we need data
sets like the bottom one to really push
them to their limits and not only that
but the authors here find that there are
even problems with that because these
image data sets they're always created
in a way that an image is given and then
the humans are asked to write a
description which is really good because
then you have image and description
together right however
the authors here know that this prevents
for example fantasy pictures like uh
we saw before the the raccoon in cubism
that it doesn't exist so it can't be in
any data set or anubis in a leather
jacket doesn't exist so it can't be in
any data set now while we rely on
generalization
during training for the model to learn
these things we actually need data sets
like that to to evaluate whether they
can really do these things right
otherwise we're left with sort of
subjective evaluation
so they come up with an with their own
data set which is called party prompts
that's actually also the thing they
release as far as understanding
obviously as uh
all of the recent
works in big models this thing isn't
released
there's no code there's no i mean the
code would be trivial there's no weights
there's no training recipe there's no
some of the data sets are proprietary if
i understand correctly
so the paper is more open about what
they do but still that there's no way of
accessing this
so party prompts this is a data set that
essentially only consists of prompts so
there's no images in this data set and i
believe the only way you can really
assess thing is you can let the model
um
generate stuff
and then you can let humans rate it
that's essentially it
the party prompts it is pretty
interesting because they
create these prompts by
letting the prompt engineers sort of
they choose for example a challenge so
the challenge might be perspective right
which could be
um
you know i need a prompt that asks for
some object in some
in some specific perspective that is
unusual
or
uh yeah quantity like i need a prompt
that
a
that asks for a given number of things
because we know that these models
they're not super good at counting right
i mean
we also thought the models aren't super
good at spelling and now it turns out
well if we just make them bigger they
are so
you know
i'm fairly confident they're going to be
good at counting in a short while uh
that's the challenge there's also if i
recall correctly oh this is this upper
table right here like categories so
there are categories animals there are
categories illustrations and so on so
you can see this is a diverse
set of category challenge combinations
and they make a bunch of prompts for
each one i think they have about 1600
prompts in total in this party prompt
eval set
which is a pretty neat thing to have
even if it comes without images
so now they train the thing with their
whole architectural shebangs with the
parallelism and the pipelining and the
yada yada yada on tpu v4s i think
so this is a huge operation so what does
that give us i want to just jump the
evals here on the metrics because yes
yes yes they're very good very good
they're also very good as rated by
humans humans very good
uh
which is what's interesting is they have
for example a retrieval baseline which
simply retrieves images from the
training data set and even if the if the
obviously
image text match the party model wins
because you can actually create an image
and not retrieve one but even in image
realism you can see the retrieval is
only slightly higher in realism right
every single image
is real that the retrieval retrieves and
still the humans rate the realism of
party almost the same which is quite
speaking for the model the loss curves
are also pretty interesting especially
interesting that the 20 billion model
here it takes quite a time to to come
down here right it kind of has to
it gets surpassed by the three billion
model initially and then uh overtakes it
which maybe means that we haven't
exactly found the right training recipes
yet for these largest of models
so this now is the
the cool part where they put the model
uh the models next to one another so
this is the same prompt with
all of these different models and you
can just see
where scale gets you this is a portrait
photo of a kangaroo wearing an orange
hoodie and blue sunglasses standing on
the grass in front of the sydney opera
house holding a sign on the chest that
says welcome friends
and
you can see my this these these things
right here this and this there may be
like dolly mini kind of style
pictures and they're also that scale
right and then we go to the the 3b model
and this is something that would be
familiar maybe from something like uh
dali or dali maybe between dolly and
dolly too right these things you can see
they're bad at spelling but as soon as
you go bigger all of a sudden welcome
friends
there it is not bad at spelling anymore
all you need is scale that's crazy the
sign very deep learning
look as the model learns to spell
um initially it can only do russian or
whatever and
and just eventually it would actually be
funny if that was like
actual russian and it said very deep
learning can you imagine how crazy that
would be well in any case and also the
grand canyon right
so that there's kind of structure here
and so on but this very the very deep
learning perfect
a blue porsche
part in front of a yellow brick wall you
can see doesn't always work
but it works better and better and
better with scale
crazy and here
this is like maybe like is this a direct
shot at gary marcus because the
challenge is like an
astronaut riding a horse
so astronaut riding a horse in the
forest even the three billion model
oh no it's going to be a horse riding an
astronaut which is going to come up
later and i promise it's going to be
funny
um but yeah an astronaut riding a horse
in the water
in front of them water lilies and so on
a map of the united states made out of
sushi
so as you can see these these results
are fairly insane infinity the back of a
violin four cats surrounding a dog so
now they're really testing these
individual categories infinity is an
abstract concept back of violin is
perspective for cats surrounding a dog
is this quantity metric you can you can
see there are four cuts right so
yeah i'm pretty confident that with with
scale these types of problems are going
to be solved scroll gives an apple to a
bird
um yeah so
what's interesting is they
have this narrative of what they call
growing a cherry tree so obviously these
samples here are cherry picked which
means that they take out whatever they
think are good samples to present in the
paper however they detail fairly
extensively how they arrive at this
thing so
what they do is they don't just come up
with these long prompts by themselves
well these aren't long okay but you know
these long prompts with anubis in front
in a leather jacket in front of los
angeles skyline they don't just come up
with them on the spot they have a
process of coming up with them
and the process is detailed here so for
example they
have this idea of combining like a sloth
with a van right so they start by just
exploring the model
and entering things like a smiling sloth
like
what comes out right and a van parked on
grass there are always good images and
bad images that turn out and they sort
of learn how to have to tweak the prompt
to get what they want once they're happy
they go on
so they modify the prompt a bit so there
is the smiling sloth wearing a leather
jacket the cowboy hat and the kilt
or wearing a bow tie and holding a
corridor staff
so they kind of explore they go more and
more as you can see as you go down this
tree this cherry tree as they call it
they go down and down they detail well
sometimes there's problems uh this one i
believe has two
two arms on this side and so on so
but still they refine and refine and
refine they finally try to combine them
right
um yeah here is here is a combination
they refine again they try to combine
the two prompts again
and
at the end they get to something that
they might be happy with for example the
thing here on the left
um like this one right here but i found
this pretty interesting like this
process of arriving at these things so
you can't just enter any old long
sentence and expect the model to do well
but what turns what
might
what will work often better at least as
they describe it is to go through this
process
right here which also means that
full artistic freedom is a bit away so
it is almost like
yes you are guiding the model with your
inputs but also the model is kind of
guiding you by what it does well and
what it doesn't do well if you go via
this process and if you don't go via
this process then i guess you can expect
that um
you
you can expect that it might not work as
well
so they also have some failure cases
which is pretty cool for example um
the failure cases like color bleeding
where you describe the color of one of
the things in the image and sort of the
other
take on that um
that color
uh there's also counting failures and so
on localization failures for example
here the prompt is the prompt is
um
oh yeah the great pyramid of giza
situated in front of mount everest
that's the bottom two pictures should be
that
you can see this okay i mean this isn't
this isn't too bad
um but this here is just like the
pyramid with sort of a mount everest
cover right you can see these models
they sometimes
if they can't fulfill the problem
directly they'll kind of mix they'll
they'll just try to get it done somehow
and get it really close in text
embedding space that's exactly what you
can see right here
um
[Music]
there's a bunch a bunch of examples and
this one i told you it's the horse
riding on an astronaut
so they have to actually
specify the horses sitting on an
astronaut because the riding is just is
just riding indicates too much that the
horse is on the bottom
but i just found the horse riding on the
astronaut to be absolutely hilarious
especially this one
um yeah but
all in all i guess what i wanted to say
is that
this
is complaining on a on a very very high
level right the the paper itself is like
moving the goal posts already by sort of
criticizing itself for
oh well i specified like nine apples in
a perfect arrangement i don't have or
right
ten red apples and it's only eight red
apples like what a what a loser model
look at that i mean this is it is
crazy good how these models are
and
the failure cases here are
you know
yes they're failure cases but i don't
think that if you told me three four
years ago that this is the type of error
that we're at solving um that i would
have said yeah i i believe that i would
have
way guessed we're still at the point
where you know we we have mode collapses
we can't create most of the text stuff
we have artifacts and all kinds of
things and
i think this is
yeah it's it's kind of
mind-blowing how fast the progress here
is
obviously half a year ago or so yeah i
would have expected something like this
but i believe
yeah a lot of people
must be very surprised
and including me
yeah like
spelling mistakes like complaining that
you know sometimes text is still not
spelled right like nah
even though right dali couldn't do it at
all
and now this thing is doing it almost
perfectly as you can see right here
combining abstract concepts look at the
thing on top it's
it's insane or here like oh this leg is
in a behind the race car
come on
this is uh
better than i guess anyone had expected
so
um yeah i don't want to waste your time
too much more i just thought this was
absolutely cool and i'm very excited to
see where this is going next uh of
course huge bummer that we don't get
access to this i hope this finds its way
into some products that we can use uh as
you know i'm all for these companies
um making
making money with their inventions i
mean i think it's cool that they are
inventing and
you know if they want to make some cash
off of it
uh you know good for them
but i do hope that we actually get to
use it
and uh i
it's going to be a fun future where for
every presentation or anything if you
need like an illustration you just you
just type it right you don't go to the
internet to search an appropriate stock
photo you just type it it's so cool or
you want to change something in a
picture you just erase it you just say
whatever here
change that part to something else so
cool no photoshop skills anymore no
drawing skills anymore just you and your
mind and your creativity
all right that was it
um as i said the paper presented
in this new system is fairly simple all
it does is scale a bunch of transformers
in sequence essentially
i presented a evaluation benchmark these
party prompts
and it presented yeah their their model
which is
ridiculously
insane
that was it for me uh let me know what
you think and i'll see you around bye